[MUSIC PLAYING]
[CLAPPING AND CHEERING]
MALE SPEAKER 1: Good morning,
Welcome to Google I/O 2015.
As always we live-stream
IO to over 460 locations
across six continents.
When we say, be
together, not the same,
that is precisely what we mean.
We want to provide
Android for users the way
they like it so that
it works for them.
MALE SPEAKER 2:
There are hundreds
of new features in the app,
and you'll find improvements
to the core user
experience peppered
throughout the release.
MALE SPEAKER 3: We're
making it easier
for you to develop your
app, engage your users,
and earn with Google.
MALE SPEAKER 4: We're
giving you the biggest
update to the
material guidelines
since we launched them.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Android
is not only for mobile,
we are taking computing
beyond mobile as well.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: We're
working on a new capability
to assist you in the moment
wherever you are on the phone.
We're calling it Now on tap.
MALE SPEAKER 5:
Google Photos-- a home
for all your photos and videos,
so that you can share and save
what matters.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: We're
launching a new family
discovery experience that makes
it much easier for parents
to find high-quality
family friendly content.
MALE SPEAKER 1:
Behind me you're going
to see a single dot for every
Android active phone out there.
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: This
is a huge opportunity
for Android developers.
MALE SPEAKER 6: I'm
really excited to give you
a glimpse for what's next
for Cardboard and for larger
efforts in VR.
FEMALE SPEAKER 4: Together
we have the ability
to solve hard problems, problems
you can't solve by yourself.
MALE SPEAKER 7: Getting out
and getting into contact
with the real world is
the most valuable thing
you can do for your project.
MALE SPEAKER 1: This is why
I/O is so exciting for us.
We get to share what we have
been up to in the last year.
And all you developers get to
go out and build amazing things
on top of what we do.
Good luck and see you next year.
[CLAPPING AND CHEERING]